What would happen if you did a raw honey face mask
with a little bit of baking soda on your face
every single night for 14 days?
Raw honey is literally like skincare medicine.
It's enzymatic, it's antimicrobial,
it's hydrating. It feeds your face while you sleep.
And baking soda, that's like it's gritty little sidekick.
It scrubs, it rebalances your pH.
It makes inflammation pack its bags and leave you alone together.
This is skin alchemy, my friend.
Drawing out impurities, reducing the subdermal lymph stagnation,
leaving your skin looking absolutely glorious.
So my wife finally tried it,
and she took one raw teaspoon of honey.
This is all you need to do.
And a quarter teaspoon of baking soda.
Next morning, she was like,
oh, my gosh,
my skin feels different. I have no more redness.
It just feels clear, and it actually looks less inflamed.
It's so powerful. Mother Nature's medicine.
Sometimes the best skincare isn't inexpensive.
$500 serums. It's literally food that's in your medicine cabinet.
Let's get everybody just looking absolutely glorious.
I'm drew cannoli. Like, follow and save for more.